if you take gaming seriously at all you
will know that mechanical keyboards are
the kings of PC peripherals
oh the consistency durability and feel
of a mechanical keyboard is simply
unmatched by anything that a standard
membrane board could hope to offer but
with so many options out there finding
one that is perfectly suited to your
needs can be a complex and confusing
Journey most people on the hunt for a
new keep to enhance their skills fall
into one of two camps those who want the
cheapest out of the box keyboard that's
gonna get the job done and those who are
willing to drop thousands on a custom
build 3500 keyboard
however there are those of us who fall
somewhere in the middle those who want a
premium experience from a brand they
trust without breaking the bank but
where do you draw the line between
quality and cost well it seems like PC
peripheral giant Corsair has the answer
they are K100 Air Ultra Thin Wireless
mechanical keyboard is one of if not the
most expensive pre-built keyboards to
date with a shocking 280 dollar price
tag but why why is this pre-built more
expensive than some customs is its low
profile design the next big thing and if
it actually is any good
is the price tag worth it
so throughout the 2010s as competitive
PC gaming got bigger out of the box
keyboards like the Black Widow k70 and
quickfire rapid dominated the market at
both the consumer level and in Esports
but Brands were marketing so heavily
towards Competitive Gaming that it left
a bit of a hole in the mechanical
keyboard Market you see one of the
biggest draws of a mechanical keyboard
is pretty simple they just feel good to
use whether you use them to win
tournaments or just type out your
homework and although the big Brands did
eventually start offering more
customization options to the average
buyer like different switches or macro
keys some people wanted more thus began
a small community of mechanical keyboard
enthusiasts who dedicated their time and
money to building their own perfect
boards preaching the custom keep life
like a gospel along the way we often
fill our senses with rich flavors and
pleasant Aromas
but how often do we take care of the
things we touch that Community slowly
grew until it eventually exploded in
2020 with so many people stuck at home
Gamers and Discord degenerates alike
were looking for a more personalized
typing experience and custom keyboards
quickly became a way for people across
the internet to express themselves the
Ruta is the one interesting one of
course there's nice balls for you to
play with because everyone knows we love
to play with balls oh my God
look at that space
oh no
this is actually the most disgusting
thing I've ever seen But building a
custom keyboard is a double edged sword
sure if you want a bamboo case or solid
metal keycaps that's not gonna be too
hard but the most outrageous Sports can
get really expensive this is definitely
probably the most exotic anodizing we've
ever done this is all anodization this
isn't like a paint job this isn't a
coating
this is aluminum anodized to be
color thirty five hundred dollar
keyboard
so while some people were making careers
off of custom keyboards or dropping
thousands on crazy builds there were
still a ton of people that didn't have
the time or money to participate which
means that for the average consumer
pre-built keyboards remain extremely
popular but the popularity of custom
keyboards showed the pre-built keyboard
brands that people were willing to spend
a lot of money and that if they wanted
those customers they were going to need
to start releasing more Innovative
products and in the last few years we've
seen them try just about everything in
search of the mythical big spender who
doesn't want to Shell out for a custom
it's the 12.6 inch full multi-touch LCD
dominating the upper half of the unit it
features a
1920x515 Ultra wide resolution 10 point
touch screen and USBC connectivity for
easily attaching to a laptop or desktop
but recently one big Trend stands out
low profile keywords inspired heavily by
max keyboards like the Logitech 915 or
the Razer death stalker offer a Slimmer
case Chiclet keycaps and wireless
Bluetooth connection and the newest
entry into that space is the Corsair
K100 air now Corsair have been in the PC
peripherals game for a very long time
and they legitimately make everything
however corsair's newest release is well
it's really expensive the new k-100 Air
is 280 US Dollars which is not only more
expensive than any of its competitors
but basically any other pre-built on the
market and that Hefty price tag has
become a bigger talking point than the
actual features of the keyboard this
board is the lightest to be added to
corsair's extensive lineup and if you
rank them on price it sits firmly at the
top but let's be charitable here after
all the specs are what make this thing
so damn expensive so
what the hell are they well on top of
being able to connect to and switch
between four different devices on the
Fly this keyboard boasts a battery life
of up to 200 hours when the RGB settings
are turned off and that's pretty unheard
of on top of that the K100 air has an
aluminum face plate and is to my
knowledge the thinnest mechanical
keyboard in existence this thing is only
17 millimeters at its thickest point for
comparison the Logitech is 22 and the
Razer is 24.3 as for the rest of the
specs they're pretty standard and
honestly right about what you'd expect
from a high-end Corsair in this day and
age but that ultimately begs the
question are these features useful is
this keyboard actually any good and if
you answer to those questions is yes is
it really worth all this time and all
this money well lucky for you guys
Corsair sent this thing over to Devin
he's been using it for a couple of weeks
now and he definitely definitely has
some thoughts he'd like to share and now
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about okay before we get started
I wanted to thank Corsair for actually
sending me this keyboard to try out in
the first place but with that said this
is not a sponsored video so this review
is going to be 100 honest the keyboard
itself is absolutely as advertised it is
the thinnest mechanical keyboard I've
ever used other than a keyboard on an
actual laptop I think it actually might
be the thinnest keyboard I've used
period which is crazy now it features
risers that can give you about half an
inch incline if you don't want it flush
to your desk on the underside there's
also this triangle pattern thingy which
is cool I guess as for the board itself
it's actually pretty damn sturdy it has
this nice brush black aluminum face
plate along with this screen that shows
off LED indicators that help add to its
Sleek aesthetic since the faceplate is
metal there's some pretty damn good
weight to it plus it has a rubber strip
at the bottom so I never noticed the
keyboard moving around on my desk which
is typically a giant pet peeve of mine
for all the Zoomers out there who are
waiting with baited breath I can
confirmed that the RGB settings are what
you expect from a Corsair product as for
corsair's claims about the 50 to 200
hour battery life with full RGB settings
I got well over 50 hours without
plugging this thing back in with that
being said I honestly don't know if I'll
have this thing unplugged for more than
a couple hours so unfortunately it's
just an expense for a feature that I
won't be using that being said if you
are into wireless keyboards this one
lasts a damn long time as for a feature
I will use let's talk about the extra
keys on this thing there are four
programmable Keys along with a row of
media buttons and a lovely aluminum
volume roller it may seem insignificant
but if your computer is like mine and
has a conniption every time you all tab
then you know how important a feature
like this can be as for how it feels to
use well I actually kind of like it the
keyboard features Cherry MX ultra low
profile switches which feel amazing
they're tactile so you get that
satisfying bump the quality is what
you'd expect from Cherry and the Caps
themselves make typing feel fluid and
snappy gaming on this thing was easy
typing took a little bit longer to get
used to but honestly this keyboard is
extremely fun to use use and I haven't
experienced anything quite like it
before but as much as I enjoy using this
keyboard I don't actually think it's
worth the price tag after the first
couple days I had it I couldn't stop
thinking to myself who the hell is this
for and that's coming from someone who's
been using the same Black Widow since
2015. to be fair considering the
material quality battery and all the
other features I do think the price
makes sense I just don't know if anyone
needs all of this but with all that
being said the price isn't even my
biggest gripe it's the size this is for
whatever reason a standard full-size
keyboard which to me defeats the entire
purpose it's supposed to be ultra sleek
and portable but it's absolutely massive
lengthwise if this was a 60 or 65
keyboard and they slid this whole top
row down I'd honestly like it a lot
better incredible quality aside I just
can't convince myself that this keyboard
is actually worth it and that was the
guy who actually he knows what he's
talking about the k-100 air is a bit of
an enigma it does what it claims to do
very well it just isn't clear who it's
really suited for and if you're looking
for a keyboard with these features then
there are cheaper alternatives in fact
both the Logitech and Razer keyboards I
mentioned earlier are less expensive
than the K100 air and the key cron K3 is
Wireless low profile and is hot
swappable which of course has high end
competitors not for only 84. it may not
have all the same features or build
quality but you get so much for around a
third of the price with all that being
said I appreciate what this keyboard can
do and fully understand that there are
people out there who want a pre-built
this premium it just might not be your
average gamer
thoughts on the Mac keyboard I hate the
Mac keyboard I hate Mac keyboards
they're terrible my thoughts on Avatar
dude I keep seeing these reviews isn't
like nade shot like going ham on Twitter
about like how sick Avatar is and like
how mind-blowing I remember watching the
first movie when I was like 15 and I was
like homie this is just Pocahontas but
like 300 million dollars more expensive